[Applause]
[Music]
so as so huffin happens just as soon as
I figure I've got my handler and my head
wrapped around my schedule for the next
few weeks and as something drops and I
gotta move stuff around so the first
trailer for Joker starring Joaquin
Phoenix has dropped and I wasn't sure
like right off the bat whether I would
be addressing this or not because like
my thought was okay maybe let me look at
the trailer and see if I have enough
thoughts that like it feels worth
talking about because sometimes I see
these things and I'm like Edie
that was a trailer sure was but this
one's interesting to me for a number of
reasons so it's a pretty good trailer
like I I was gonna say objectively it's
not objective that's my opinion but I
think by most standards is a good
trailer it gives you a good sense of
feel a vibe for the character of the
story
it feels very well constructed in terms
of selling this whole concept and and
and what it's doing by concept I mean
the idea of a man pushed to frightening
extreme action and my concerns though
are about that being used to tell a
Joker story there's something about that
that doesn't quite sit right with me and
I'm kind of of two minds on but I'll get
back to that I find it interesting that
with only a couple of brief exceptions
it's very rare to see Joaquin Phoenix
giving a genuine smile like there's a
couple of forced grins you know
he does the and this and but like he
lets go in at the very edges face just
Falls like he's in the audience at a
stand-up comic and he does it's very
forced laugh I'm like cuz I genuine at
all so you know there's there's all sort
of stuff at play which is an interesting
way to play the Joker now like obviously
this is just like two minutes
like 2:30 whatever so like I don't want
to over extrapolate but the vibe I get
is that this is somebody who wants to
laugh not someone who inherently finds
all of these things in this horrible and
is funny but who really wants to find
some reason to smile which to me is an
interesting angle to come at the Joker
in terms of well he the things that make
most people laugh and smile weren't
working he went to the extreme and again
that's me extrapolating maybe the actual
product will be a little different but
that's the vibe I get and I think that's
an interesting one to take that I
apparently like the kid that he does
this to also supposedly that's young
Bruce Wayne that strikes me as
unnecessary so like I didn't need that
Manion Oh in my mind hopefully it's not
or or if it is they don't state that
outright and like maybe they just hint
at it but you know I I'm not sure like
if you're gonna do this kind of Joker so
you don't need Bruce especially a young
Bruce like especially with Gotham going
you know not that Gotham is the end-all
be-all but like it doesn't feel like a
novel idea or actually even compared to
like the 89 Batman which would have had
a similar age gap between Joker and
Batman so yeah like if that is in fact
young Bruce Wayne don't love that I like
the you know the the music choice the
sort of overall build to the thing it's
it's really well put together but that
so the thing that was kind of gnawing at
me that was made me kind of going
and part of this is tied to my inherent
dislike of the idea of an origin for the
Joker I'm not gonna say that any origins
of the Joker is bad but I think the
Joker just inherently works better
without a clear-cut origin and it's and
it's hard to do it without running into
what I'm afraid will happen in this
movie now I'm not going to necessarily
say this is what the movie will be but
based off this trailer this is what I'm
afraid of seeing and I hope it's not the
case but here's what I'm afraid of I am
afraid of them over justifying what he
becomes
and what I mean by that is this trailer
spends a fair amount of time beating him
up
I mean quite literally he gets assaulted
at what looks like his job he gets
assaulted on the train he seems to be
getting hassled by everybody who isn't
his mother and what worries me about
that is I I kind of fear the character
becoming glorified or feeling justified
in the actions he will eventually take
because the world was so cruel to him so
like to make a comparison to some of the
ways that this can this can go wrong
I'll mention two movies one that I think
is a more direct comparison for what is
that I'm afraid happening and the other
one being not as directed comparison but
a movie more people probably know so the
movie that more people probably know
would be Fight Club and Tyler Durden now
if you pay attention Tyler Durden 'he's
the villain of that movie but he still
got idolized by certain swath of the
audience because so much work was done
to make him charismatic which absolutely
has a story function but as far as
overall messaging of the movie makes
things very muddled because the coolest
guy in the movie is
you know he's so charismatic that it's
possible to get wrapped up in the in the
philosophy he's espousing even though
the tail end of the movie demonstrates
what's wrong with it
a more one-to-one comparison in a movie
that I don't think is well I know is not
as well known as Fight Club was a movie
called falling down which was a Michael
Douglas movie about a guy who basically
snaps in like just starts lashing out
and it's presented in a way that feels
very justified and it does build over
time and it it tries at the end like try
and make clear note he actually was the
bad guy like Michael Douglas's I mean
spoilers for falling down I guess if you
haven't seen it by now you're probably
not going to at the very end mile
Douglass goes I'm the bad guy how did
that happen but that acknowledgment
comes so late that I feel like people
are people have a tendency to over
identify with somebody horrible and not
in a way that makes you go oh god I
shouldn't be relating to this monster in
a way that makes you go yeah you do that
stuff you monster and like there's no
way for me to talk about this and not
get SJW cuck triggered beta stamp to
write across my forehead so like I'm
just gonna own that there's just
something that worries me about this
presenting things in a way that makes
the Joker feel justified or in any way
righteous because I love the Joker but
there's already kind of a cult of
personality around this character that
concerns me at times you know there are
there are fans who idolize this
character in a way that I find
unsettling and any portrayal of this
character that feels like it might feed
into that end of things that will make
me nervous again I don't know if this
film will actually do that I'm just
worried that it will here's the sort of
saving grace that I saw and I'm hoping
get
played for nuance rather than just raw
sympathy which is going to be however to
what extent they acknowledge or deal
with mental illness now this is actually
in some ways gonna be a minefield
because actually this is a big part of
how other sort of attempts at giving
some version of an origin to the Joker
have avoided this like the most famous
is the Killing Joke and the version you
know the possible origin for the Joker
given there is sort of the most famous
because basically like this one guy just
has the world's worst day and he snaps
and that is fairly relatable but it's
made clear in that same story that there
is something wrong with him that made
him respond to this in a way that is not
typical and not representative of how
most people would respond and that's
demonstrated with the fact that the
Joker in that story the Joker tries to
break Gordon and fails and Batman points
this very thing out yes the world is
harsh but maybe it's not that you had a
bad day maybe it's you and that that was
important to get in there and balance it
out so there is if you read the the
notebook that the Joey that the Joker
scribbling in it says jokes at the top
if you actually read that the thing at
the bottom says the worst thing about
having a mental illness is is being
expected to protect like you don't and
first of all that's actually yeah like
that solid observation and and you can
see just in the way the jokes are
written out that that yeah he hits him
you know the the reality of that so like
an acknowledgment that there's something
off about him has been used in the past
to like balance this kind of thing but
it's potentially a minefield depending
on how they deal with it and how
specific they get with whatever they
decide his mental condition
is because then it's just slipping into
mentally ill people as dangerous and
that's a whole other candle wouldn't in
which like the Joker does feed into it
to a certain extent but again it's one
of those things that helps because a you
know grandfather clause the guy's been
around for so dang long you kind of get
away with it but also that his his
madness has never been diagnosed as
anything real
he is he is comic book crazy so having
it be that has this kind of a big part
of how I you know the comics get away
with it and various movie adaptations
have never gotten very specific or
really delved into the mental illness
end of it because team to dig into that
more if you can thread the needle and
like that's a tiny target that you need
to get just right you could have a lot
of nuance and a lot of interesting
layers to this character but if you miss
that really tiny mark it's it can come
off as tone deaf or exploitative or just
incredibly wrongheaded so I this trailer
makes me intrigued and nervous at the
same time because what I'm seeing I'm
like I'm kind of interested in seeing
this movie but seeing some of the ways
that it might go based off this trailer
and again not saying any of this for
certain this is all speculative this is
all impressions this is all vibe there
are things that make me go just please
be careful
so we'll see when it comes out Joker
first trailer what you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something out in the comments let's talk
a little about it buttons links patreon
much appreciated kind of need the help
but a whole bunch of other links down
there to check out besides give them a
look or don't either way it works cuz at
the end of the day folks you're the
council I'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]